let's now look at around
around the country so to speak a tour of
right-wing media reactions more
reactions to joe biden's covet diagnosis
we will start with oan this is one
american news anchor alison steinberg
gleefully reporting that president joe
biden has coveted and asking her
followers to weigh in to predict
is he gonna die
well what do you know double that double
boosted fight and just got coven what do
you think is gonna happen will we come
back and say he's so glad he got the
shots because it could have been much
worse or do you think he's gonna
let me know your thoughts down below
yeah when she says do you think he's
gonna she does kind of like the
uh neck slice motion
um i don't know if that's some kind of
strange filter by the way on this
individual unclear so that's on oan
allison steinberg gleeful about it then
we go over to newsmax where a newsmax
guest wishes biden the best
but
but i wish him the best but so again
speedy recovery we wish him the best but
i think it's time that we really refocus
on some of the issues that we have here
at home and in our backyards before we
go down the path of another double
booster and you know vaccines for kids
under five aren't those issues in our
backyard like that's very strange we
should focus on domestic issues rather
than things like whether americans get
coveted in america
sounds like a domestic issue ma'am uh we
i wish him the best but
i'm against racism but
i'm against the n word but
um and then on fox news here's another
idea
joe biden actually had coveted last
friday when he was in jerusalem or as
donald trump used to call it jerusalem
and uh
that this is harris faulkner's idea
kovid i'm harris faulkner you are in the
faulkner focus the white house has said
that he is experiencing what they are
calling mild symptoms he's now
in isolation
the president has referenced his help
during his recent visit to jerusalem in
his own words let's watch right
i
was making a speech
and
i had a terrible head of hair
excuse me a terrible headache
and uh
i'm sorry
i had a terrible headache
says years ago
and i did a very stupid thing
so again the president's struggling a
bit there we do know the white house
doctors the white house has announced uh
that they do not believe his symptoms
from covid began before
yesterday that was last friday what we
showed you
just for perspective
that's perspective in the faulkner focus
on fox news
uh i mean listen the timing of it
suggests that he probably didn't have
covid last friday um i'm guessing that
with a cough like that he would be
tested
it doesn't really make sense the timing
of it doesn't really make sense by the
way it does bear mentioning
that we know
donald trump knew he had covered during
that presidential debate with joe biden
and he found a way to not have to test
at the venue to just show up and say i
had a negative test
and um that's crazy that's completely
and totally nuts so there was no mention
of that by fox news at the time but
here's a story that they will gladly
speculate on even if it doesn't really
make too much sense so
basically as expected reporting on
biden's covet diagnosis anti-vaxx
glee
uh speculation about whether he will die
conspiracies about karma and pretending
to have cancer just about everything you
could imagine
we have the next david pakman show
viewer town hall coming up tuesday july
26th at 6 pm eastern
everyone's welcome to call in we will
open the phone lines via discord
and i will just take questions question
after question after question it will be
streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel that's the other youtube
channel
youtube.compacmanlive i hope you'll be
there and i also hope that you'll sign
up at joinpakman.com and become a member
when you are a member
you get a priority phone line to call
into the town halls which is
i would say a beautiful thing you can
use the coupon code obamina
to get a discount off of your membership
at joinpakman.com we'll take a quick
break
great to see you here on this friday
show
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below